Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von DLR und ESA rund um die Raumfahrt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und für die heutige Ausgabe haben wir uns mal wieder eine Mission vorgenommen, die wir etwas genauer ergründen wollen. Und dazu bin ich nach Garching bei München gefahren und befinde mich am Max-Planck-Institut für extraterrestrische Physik und begrüße als heutigen Gesprächspartner Joachim Trümper.
Guten Tag.
Sie sind jetzt, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch der erste Gast, der jetzt nicht explizit DLR- oder ESA-Mitarbeiter ist. Nichtsdestotrotz gab es eine sehr enge Kooperation mit dem DLR. Das Projekt, über das wir sprechen wollen, ist der ROSAT, der Röntgensatellit, der schon vor einiger Zeit seine Dienste verrichtet hat. Also ein Projekt, das schon etwas länger zurückliegt. Sie waren ja ganz maßgeblich bei der Entstehung dieses Projektes beteiligt. Bevor wir da vielleicht drauf eingehen, ich denke, ich trete die nicht zu nahe, aber ich sage, sie sind ein alter Hase im Weltraumgeschäft. Wann sind sie denn zu diesem Thema gekommen? Was hat sie denn dem Weltraum näher gebracht?
Gut, also ich habe in Halle Hamburg und Kiel studiert, war dann in Kiel etliche Jahre an einem Institut für Kernphysik. Ich bin also sozusagen gelernter Kernphysiker und bin dann zur Astronomie gekommen durch die Entdeckung der Pulsare im Jahre 1967. Das hat mich sehr fasziniert, weil die Pulsare sozusagen Manifestation der Kernphysik sind. Und ich habe mich von da an mit diesen Objekten beschäftigt.
Was heißt das, dass es eine Manifestation der Kernphysik ist?
Neutronensterne sind im Grunde riesige Atomkerne. Wir bestehen ja aus Atomen und jedes Atom hat einen Atomkern, der eine sehr, sehr hohe Dichte hat. Diese Atomkerne sind winzige Objekte in unserem Körper. In jedem Atom steckt ein Atomkern. Neutronensterne sind riesige Atomkerne im Grunde, die etwa die 1,4-fache Sonnenmasse haben und sie entstehen, wenn sternen ausgebrannt sind, massereiche Sterne ausgebrannt sind, dann kollabieren die zu Neutronensternen zu sehr, sehr hohen Dichten. Also in einem Neutronenstern herrschen Dichten von einer Größenordnung, Milliarden Tonnen pro Kubikzentimeter.
Das ist schon recht eng beieinander, kann man sagen.
Ja, das sind also hochverdichtete Objekte und die Dichten, die Materiedichten in einem Neutronenstern, sind noch mal um Faktor 4 oder 5 größer als die in unseren Atomkernen, die wir in uns haben, weil einfach bei den Neutronensternen noch die Gravitation dazukommt, die das Ganze zusammenpresst. Die Entdeckung dieser Neutronensterne als Radiopulsare im Jahr 1967 hat mich fasziniert als Kernphysiker und ich bin dann in den darauffolgenden Jahren sozusagen langsam in die Astrophysik hinübergedriftet.
Und das hat sie dann irgendwann auch zum Max-Planck-Institut gebracht?
Nein. Ich hatte also bis 1971 am Schluss eine Professorenstelle an der Universität Kiel, wo ich auch promoviert hatte und wo ich mich also lange Zeit auch mit Kernphysik beschäftigt habe. Ich habe dann 1971 oder 1970 einen Ruf bekommen an die Universität Tübingen auf einen Lehrstuhl für Astronomie, weil ich mich inzwischen in der Astrophysik getummelt habe und weil ich vorhatte, ein Programm für die Röntgenastronomie in Deutschland anzufangen. Ich war also dann an der Universität Tübingen, Direktor des Astronomischen Instituts und Lehrstuhlinhaber des Lehrstuhls für Astronomie. Das war übrigens der Lehrstuhl, den Johannes Kepler nicht bekommen hat. Und von dort aus bin ich hier an dieses Institut berufen worden, an das Max-Planck-Institut 1974, 1975, weil ich mich in Tübingen inzwischen mit der Röntgenastronomie beschäftigt hatte. Wir hatten ein Programm zur kosmischen Röntgenastronomie begonnen, mit Höhenforschungsballonen, also nicht mit Satelliten, sondern mit Höhenforschungsballonen und mit Raketen. Und ich hatte also im Jahr 1975 schon an gewissen Namen auf dem Gebiet umgehend hier an das Max-Planck-Institut berufen worden.
Und ich habe es jetzt schon herausgehört, Röntgenastronomie hat jetzt schon relativ früh eine Rolle gespielt, also auch schon in Tübingen. Warum? Hängt das mit den Pulsaren auch zusammen?
Das hängt auch mit den Pulsaren zusammen, aber ganz allgemein kann man sagen, in der optischen Astronomie, also in der Lichtastronomie, da sehen wir ja nur einen ganz schmalen Ausschnitt aus dem gesamten elektromagnetischen Spektrum. Ein Faktor zwei in Wellenlängen sind es vom roten bis zum blauen Bereich. Und man benutzt heute in der Astronomie viele Dekaden, etwa 80 Oktaven an Wellenlängen, verglichen mit der einen Oktave, die man im sichtbaren Bereich hatte. Und zuerst war bereits in den 30 Jahren die Radioastronomie entstanden, in den 50er Jahren dann die Gamma-Astronomie, die Gamma-Strahlenastronomie und dann kam die Röntgenastronomie dazu in den 60er Jahren und weitere Spektralbereiche. Also heute benutzt man für die astronomische Informationsgewinnung den gesamten Bereich von den langwelligen Radiowellen, bei Wellenlängen von etwa 100 Metern oder so, das sind also Radiowellen, bis zum hochenergetischen Gamma-Bereich. Und das ist eine enorme Informationsvermehrung in der Astronomie.
Was war denn der ausschlaggebende Punkt, dass jetzt die Röntgenastronomie so in den Mittelpunkt des Interesses?
Gut, also sie ist in den Mittelpunkt meines Interesses und vieler anderer Wissenschaftler gekommen, weil man mit der Röntgenastronomie gerade stark kollabierte Objekte sehr gut beobachten kann. Neutronensterne, über die wir schon kurz gesprochen hatten, oder auch schwarze Löcher, die sind noch stärker komprimiert als Neutronensterne. Und durch die Röntgenastronomie haben sich da also ganz neue Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten erschlossen. Diese Objekte, die konnte man im optischen Spektralbereich zunächst überhaupt gar nicht sehen, weil die viel zu klein sind. Aber im Röntgenbereich kann man sie sehen, weil vor allem dann, wenn Materie auf diese Objekte einfällt, zum Beispiel, wenn Materie auf einen Neutronenstern einfällt, dann wird die Materie enorm beschleunigt auf etwa ein Drittel der Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Und wenn sie auf den Neutronenstern aufprallt, dann entsteht ein heißes Plasma mit Temperaturen bis zu 100 Millionen Grad und das sendet intensive Röntgenschleunung aus.
Das heißt, was man beobachten kann, ist quasi das Auftreffen der Materie auf diesen Neutronenstern?
Nicht das Auftreffen selbst, aber das heiße Plasma, was dabei entsteht. Weil es wird dann die kinetische Energie des einfallenden Materials praktisch in Wärmeenergie umgewandelt. Und dabei entstehen sehr, sehr hohe Temperaturen und eine sehr intensive Röntgenschleunung. Bei meinem Lieblingsstern Hercules X1, den wir in den 70er Jahren viel beobachtet haben, da kommen ungefähr 100 Milliarden Tonnen in der Sekunde mit einem Drittel oder der halben Lichtgeschwindigkeit herunter. Also ein kosmischer Wasserfall mit unglaublichen Dimensionen.
Mit welchen Mitteln konnte man denn damals das dann beobachten? Also wie fängt man denn diese Röntgenstrahlung?
Also die Entdeckung der ersten Röntgenquelle, der ersten kosmischen Röntgenquelle, passierte im Jahr 1992 von dem Team von Riccardo Giacconi, mit dem wir dann später auch zusammengearbeitet haben. Und der 2002, glaube ich, den Nobelpreis für Physik für die Entdeckung der Röntgenastronomie bekommen hat. Bei dieser ersten Quelle, die man damals beobachtete, handelte es sich um einen materie- sammelnden, akkretierenden Neutronenstern. Also gerade um die Situation, die ich eben beschrieben habe. Das war im Jahr 1962.
Ist das eigentlich Zufall oder sind das so die stärksten Inwitter?
Das war zunächst Zufall. Was man damals versuchte, war, die Röntgenstrahlung vom Mond zu beobachten.
Hat der eine?
Der Mond ist ein kaltes Objekt und er hat natürlich keine Röntgenemission. Röntgenstrahlung entsteht bei Temperaturen von Millionen bis Milliarden Grad. Sehr hohen Temperaturen. Der Mond hat keine Eigenstrahlung, aber die Sonne hat eine Röntgenemission, die übrigens schon 1948 in den USA entdeckt wurde mit Hilfe von V2-Raketen.
Die entsprechende Messgeräte an Bord hatten?
Die entsprechende Messgeräte an Bord hatten. Die Sonne ist also eine Röntgenquelle. Die Röntgenstrahlung der Sonne kommt aus der heißen Corona, die die Sonne umgibt. Das ist ein Plasma von ein bis zwei Millionen Grad. Bei so hohen Temperaturen entsteht Röntgenstrahlung. Diese Röntgenstrahlung trifft den Mond und wird vom Mond reflektiert. Danach hat man damals gesucht. Das hing mit der Vorbereitung der Apollo-Mission zusammen. Die Amerikaner wollten zum Mond fliegen. Sie wollten sich auch vorher über die Strahlungsumgebung des Mondes informieren. Bei diesem Raketen-Experiment 1962 gelang es aber nicht, den Mond im Röntgenbereich zu sehen. Wir wissen heute, der ist viel zu schwach. Mit dem damaligen Mittel hätte man das nicht geschafft. Stattdessen hat man ein Stück entfernt vom Mond am Himmel durch Zufall diese helle Röntgenquelle im Sternbild Skorpion gefunden.
Aber man glaubte noch, es sei der Mond vielleicht.
Nein, nein. Die Winkelauflösung der Instrumente war sehr schlecht, aber man konnte schon erkennen, dass diese Strahlung von einer anderen Stelle am Himmel kommt. Und so hat es dann angefangen. Dann hat man also immer weiter geforscht, zuerst mit Raketenexperimenten in den 60er Jahren. Raketenexperimente tragen die Detektoren nur für vier oder fünf Minuten in die Hochatmosphäre. Man muss, um Röntgenstrahlung zu detektieren, aus der Atmosphäre raus. Weil die Erdatmosphäre, die hat ja eine Schichtdicke, entsprechend zehn Meter Wasser, die absorbiert die Röntgenstrahlung von kosmischen Objekten vollständig. Die Raketenexperimente hatten also relativ kurze Beobachtungszeiten, vier oder fünf Minuten.
Wie hoch müssen die fliegen, damit sie überhaupt eine Chance haben?
Oberhalb hundert Kilometer. Eine Alternative hat sich dann bald entwickelt und die haben wir dann auch zuerst ergriffen, nämlich mit Höhenforschungsballonen, Höhenforschungsballone, die gehen in die Stratosphäre bis zu Höhen oberhalb von 40, 50 Kilometern und in den Höhen kann man relativ harter Röntgenstrahlung sehen und diese Neutronensterne, die Materie aufsammeln und sehr hell sind, die haben auch eine Emission von harter Röntgenstrahlung. Und die Ballonexperimente haben gegenüber den Raketenexperimenten den Vorteil, dass man Beobachtungszeiten hat von Stunden bis Tagen. So lange bleiben die Ballone oben. Das sind riesige Ballone gewesen, die wir damals benutzt haben, die oben auf der Betriebshöhe in 40-50 Kilometern einen Durchmesser von 100 Metern haben.
100 Metern?
Und die Nutzlasten, die wir da geflogen haben, die hatten eine gute Tonne.
Oh, das ist ja richtig viel. Und wie groß ist dieser Ballon gewesen, als er dann wieder auf der Erde ist?
Na gut, also der kommt dann am Ende des Fluges. Wenn der Ballon aus der Reichweite der Radargeräte raus treibt und der Bodenstation, die die Signale von der Apparatur auffängt, wenn er droht, rauszutreiben, dann wird die Nutzlast vom Ballon abgeschnitten.
Das heißt, er ist gar nicht zurückgekommen?
Er kommt, ja, also die Nutzlast kommt dann an einem Fallschirm runter und landet irgendwo in der Wüste. Diese Ballonflüge fanden in Wüstengebieten statt, in Texas, in Australien, in Südamerika. Und dort hat man also dafür ideale Bedingungen. Die Ballone hier in Mitteleuropa, die haben das Problem, dass man durch die Luftstraßen durch muss. Und damals schon gab es da große Schwierigkeiten mit der Flugsicherung. Wir hatten in Kiel am Anfang Ballonexperimente gemacht, haben das dann aber bald aufgegeben, weil die Randbedingungen durch die Flugsicherung viel zu stark waren.
Das heißt, die Wüsten haben sich angeboten, weil einerseits nicht viel konkurrierender Verkehr war, andererseits weil man problemlos die Luftlast irgendwo landen lassen konnte.
Landen konnte und wenn da eine Tonne oder ein paar Tonnen an einem Fallschirm runterkommen, dann ist da natürlich auch was los.
Ja, da ist ein bisschen Sand ganz hilfreich beim Auftreffen. Aber die Orte als solche sind jetzt alle gleich geeignet. Also ob man jetzt über Deutschland 40 Kilometer Höhe ist oder über Australien spielt bei der Beobachtung jetzt keine Rolle.
Doch, über Deutschland oder über Texas, da sieht man gut den Nordhimmel und über Australien sieht man gut den Südhimmel.
Okay, es ist halt einfach eine andere Blickrichtung. Aber die Atmosphäre ist jetzt dieselbe Bedingung. Man hat jetzt diese Experimente gemacht. Mit den Ballonen konnte man sehr viel länger beobachten. Was hat man denn dann entdeckt? Also was hat sich denn dann sozusagen auf einmal ergeben für ein Bild? Das ist ja das erste Mal, dass man jetzt überhaupt in diesen Strahlenbereich wirklich hat intensiv reinschauen können.
Ja, dass man überhaupt hat reinschauen können. Also was man da zuerst gesehen hat mit den Raketenexperimenten und mit den Ballonexperimenten waren eben gerade diese Neutronensterne, die in Doppelsternsystemen sitzen und Masse von ihrem Begleiter, von dem normalen Stern, der sie begleitet, um den sie herumfliegen, zugeschoben bekommt. Und neben den Neutronensternen kommen da auch Schwarze Löcher in Frage. Also Doppelsternsysteme mit Neutronensternen oder Schwarzen Löchern, die sind sehr intensiv angequält. Und das waren die ersten Objekte, die man am Himmel gesehen hat. Davon konnte man durch Raketen- und Ballonexperimente so etwa 40, 50, 60 Stück am ganzen Himmel erreichen. Die waren hell genug.
In einer Messung sogar?
Nicht in einer Messung. Also in einer Messung bei Raketenexperimenten konnte man ein Objekt anschauen. Bei Ballonexperimenten, da haben wir manchmal auch zwei oder drei verschiedene Quellen nacheinander eingeschaut. Im Laufe von vielen Stunden.
Woher wusste man denn, wohin man jetzt schauen will? Wenn das so das erste Mal war, dass man sich den Himmel eigentlich unter diesem Aspekt angeschaut hat, musste man ja im Prinzip erstmal suchen.
Ja, gut. Also die Instrumente, die wir geflogen haben und andere Leute geflogen haben, die waren mit Sternsensoren und mit Sonnensensoren ausgerüstet. Das heißt, wir haben uns am optischen Himmel orientiert, an den Sternbildern gewissermaßen. Das sind relativ komplizierte Objekte. Man hat in den damals primitiven Bordcomputern die Sternbildkonfiguration gehabt, wo man hinschauen wollte. Man hat sich an dieser Sternbildkonfiguration festgehalten, mit der Beobachtungsrichtung, durch einen Kontrollbechanismus. Das ist später bei den Satellitenexperimenten im Prinzip auch so gewesen. Man muss sich also irgendwie orientieren am Himmel.
In den Seefahrern war es ja auch schon so.
Genau, und dazu dient der optische Sternhimmel mit Sternkameras.
Aber dann muss man ja erst mal suchen. Man muss ja erst mal gucken, wo ist denn jetzt überhaupt eine Röntgen?
Das hat sich sukzessive entwickelt. Also bei der ersten Röntgenbeobachtung von Scorpius X-1, da war der Fehler in der Ortsbestimmung 20 Grad. 20 Grad ist riesig. Das sind 40 Vollmonddurchmesser. Unsicherheit in der Position. Man wusste also nur ungefähr in der Richtung ist das. Aber durch technische Tricks und so weiter ist es dann gelungen, in der Raketen- und Ballon-Ära bald die Genauigkeiten auf Bogenminuten herunterzubringen. Das räumliche Auflösungsvermögen des menschlichen Auges beträgt etwa zwei bis drei Bogenminuten. Genauer können wir gar nicht. So viele Pixel haben Sie nicht in Ihrem Sensor. Also da ist man dann in den 70er Jahren bald angelangt bei diesen Größenordnungen. Und damit kann man natürlich schon sehr schön Astronomie treiben.
Was hat man jetzt im Wesentlichen gefunden? Sie sagten ja, Doppelsterne sind da sehr aktiv schwarze Löcher. Und die Pulsare, die das jetzt ursprünglich das Interesse mal ausgelöst haben, die da eine gleiche Rolle?
Ja, die aktivsten Pulsare, die am schnellsten rotierenden Pulsare, senden auch Röntgenschleimung aus. Genau wie die Radiostrahlung und zwar mit derselben Frequenz. Also zum Beispiel der berühmte Krepppulsar, der sendet 30 Pulse pro Sekunde aus. Und die hat man also auch früh erkannt. Aber die meisten und die hellsten Quellen, das sind diese Doppelsternsysteme mit Neutronensternen und Schwarzen Löchern. Die wichtigste Entdeckung, die wir gemacht haben, in den 70er Jahren war die Entdeckung der sogenannten Zyklotron-Linie in einem dieser Objekte. Das ist eine Spektrallinie im Röntgenbereich, aus der man direkt das Magnetfeld des Neutronensterns berechnen kann. Das ist die Zyklotron-Frequenz der hochenergetischen Elektronen, die da in diesem heißen Plasma an der Polkappe strahlen. Die Frequenz dieser Spektrallinie oder die Energie dieser Spektrallinie ist direkt proportional zum Magnetfeld. Wir haben damals zum ersten Mal das Polare Magnetfeld, also der Dronenstern, gemessen. Das hat damals viel Aufsehen erreicht. Bei dem Objekt ist die Magnetfeldstärke 500 Millionen Tesla. Ein normaler starker Magnet hat etwa einen Tesla. Ein Elektromagnet, ein starker Elektromagnet. Die stärksten Magnetfelder, die man im Labor, im erdischen Labor herstellen kann, sind von der Größenordnung zig Tesla.
Und der hat gleich 500 Millionen Tesla.
Ich muss es leider umrechnen, 500 Millionen Tesla.
Häftig. Das hat dann wahrscheinlich dazu geführt, dass das internationale Interesse an Röntgenastronomie enorm angestellt ist.
Ja, es hat damit beigetragen. Ich will nicht die Bedeutung von dieser Entdeckung übertreiben, aber es war eben die erste Messung eines Neutronensternmagnetfeldes. In Fachkreisen hat das großes Interesse erregt und mit vielen anderen Entdeckungen zusammen hat das die Röntgenastronomie dann auch noch interessanter gemacht, als sie schon war.
Aber irgendwann kann man dann sozusagen auch an die Grenze des Messbaren mit den Methoden, die einem zur Verfügung standen.
Richtig, genau. Wir hatten über die Begrenzung schon gesprochen. Bei den Raketenexperimenten sind es die kurzen Beobachtungszeiten. Bei den Ballonexperimenten sind die Beobachtungszeiten zwar länger, Tage, wenn man Glück hat, oder Stunden, aber die Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten sind begrenzt. Und für diese ganze Astronomie mit Raketen und mit Ballonen kommen am Himmel eigentlich nicht viel mehr als 100 Quellen in Frage, am ganzen Himmel. Da hat natürlich dann einen großen Fortschritt gebracht die Benutzung von Satelliten. Der erste berühmte Röntgensatellit war der Uhuru, der auch von Riccardo Giacconi, also dem Entdecker der ersten kosmischen Röntgenquelle, gebaut wurde. Der war der Initiator dieses Projekts. Der Uhuru ist 1971 bis 1973 geflogen und hat insgesamt gut 300 Röntgenquellen am Himmel entdeckt.
Ein NASA-Projekt war das?
Das war ein NASA-Projekt und die haben den ersten Sky Survey im Röntgenbereich gemacht. Die haben also den ganzen Himmel abgescannt und haben da diese etwa 340 Quellen gefunden. Die meisten solche Doppelsternsysteme mit Neutronensternen, Schwarz und Löchern, aber auch Supernova-Explosionen, also die Überreste von Sternexplosionen und einige andere spezielle Quellen. Das war also Anfang der 70er Jahre. Bei unserem Ballonprogramm, das wir in Tübingen 1971 angefangen haben, ging es darum, die von Uhuru entdeckten Röntgenquellen im hochenergetischen Röntgenbereich mit Ballonen zu beobachten. Uhuru hatte nur einen relativ engen Energiebereich, von 2-6 kIV Quantenenergie, und wir haben die Quellen, die von Uhuru entdeckt waren, dann beobachtet bei Energien von 20-200 kIV, also bei sehr viel höheren Energien. Dabei ist dann auch die Entdeckung von dieser Zyklotronlinie und etliche andere Entdeckungen gelungen. Und damals gab es solche Detektoren für die harte Röntgenastronomie, für die harte Röntgenstrahlung, die hochenergetische Röntgenstrahlung, noch nicht auf Satelliten. Auf Satelliten, das kam dann erst später, dass man auch in den hochenergetischen Röntgenbereich auf Satelliten gegangen ist. Insofern haben wir da mit den Ballonexperimenten zusammen mit ein, zwei anderen Gruppen in der Welt sozusagen Pionierarbeit geleistet.
Was sind denn das überhaupt für Instrumente, die diese Röntgenstrahlung detektieren? Und was kann man aus dieser Röntgenstrahlung konkret herauslesen? Was detektiert man real?
Das sind eigentlich kernphysikalische Messinstrumente, Proportionalzähler. Also das ist eine Art von Geiger-Müller-Zähler, bei der aber die Energie des einfallenden Quant gemessen werden kann. Die Energie oder die Wellenlänge. Man kann also mit diesen Detektoren Spektroskopie treiben. Die Proportionalzähler, die funktionieren im niedrigen Röntgenbereich, beim wenigen KIV, und das war der Energiebereich von HURU, bei höheren Energien haben wir Zintillationszähler benutzt. Das sind also Festkörperzähler, wie sie in der Kernphysik, auch für die Gamma-Strahlenspektroskopie benutzt werden. Die Instrumentation in Röntgenastronomie ist mindestens am Anfang sehr stark von der Kernphysik befruchtet worden. Da hat man an die Laborinstrumente eben einfach angepasst, an die Bedingungen von Raketenflügen und Ballonflügen. Ich habe 1974 einen Vorschlag für einen deutschen Röntgensatelliten gemacht. Der Antrieb war, dass wir sehr viel mehr von diesen Quellen sehen wollten. Und zwar unter Einsatz einer neuen Technologie mit Hilfe von Wolter-Teleskopen. Der Kieler Physiker Hans Wolter hatte Anfang der 50er Jahre Optiken erfunden, mit denen man Röntgenstrahlen abbilden kann. Ich kannte Wolter aus meiner Kieler Zeit. Die Amerikaner haben als Erste diese Erfindung von Wolter aufgegriffen und haben angefangen, Röntgenteleskope zu bauen. Wir haben 1972, in den Anfangszeiten meiner Tübinger Zeit, angefangen, mit der Firma Zeiss zusammen Röntgenteleskope zu entwickeln. 1974 gab es eine Ausschreibung des Bundesforschungsministeriums für wissenschaftliche Großprojekte der Grundlagenforschung. Das war eine öffentliche Ausschreibung. Und da habe ich einen Vorschlag gemacht für einen deutschen Röntgensatelliten. 1974, 1975. Das war also einige Jahre nachdem wir angefangen hatten, solche Teleskope mit Zeiss zu entwickeln.
Hatten Sie da auch schon gegründete Hoffnung, dass das auch klappen würde? Oder war das mehr so eine Wunschvorstellung?
Das war zunächst eine Wunschvorstellung. Ich meine, das ist ein Vorstand vor Stoß in das Unbekannte hinein, wenn man solche Projekte vorschlägt. Wir hatten allerdings schon eine technologische Basis. Wir hatten extraterrestrische Erfahrungen mit Raketen und auch mit den Ballonexperimenten. Wir haben in Tübingen auch Raketenexperimente im Röntgenbereich gemacht. Wir hatten also schon etwas vorzuweisen. Allerdings, das Röntgenteleskop, das dann später auf ROSAT geflogen wurde, das gab es damals noch nicht. Es hat dann noch etliche Jahre gedauert, bis das entwickelt wurde. Das BMFT bekam damals ungefähr ein Dutzend Vorschläge. Drei wurden von dem Gutachtergremium unter Leitung von Prof. Meier-Leibniz von der Technischen Universität München ausgewählt. Eins der drei war unser Röntgensatellit. Das war 1974. Dann haben wir uns aber natürlich zusammen mit dem Vorgänger der DLR, der für die raumfahrtechnische Umsetzung und für das Management verantwortlich war, im Auftrag des BMFT, haben wir uns dann in jahrelanger Arbeit mit vielen Studien und so weiter bis zu dem endgültigen ROSAT-Projekt vorgearbeitet. Der ursprüngliche Ansatz war ein sehr großes Röntgenteleskop. Mit einer Öffnung von 80 cm, also 80 cm Durchmesser von dem Röntgenspiegelsystem, war das erheblich größer als das Einstein-Observatorio, das die Amerikaner damals in der Planung hatten. Unser Vorschlag war zuerst, dieses Ding auf dem Space Shuttle zu fliegen. Und aus dem Space Shuttle rauszuwerfen, also ein Satellit, der mit dem Space Shuttle in den Orbit gebracht wird. Und das war dann für längere Zeit auch die Grundlage für unsere Industriestudien und so weiter.
In welchem Jahr befinden wir uns, weil Space Shuttle jetzt in den 80er Jahren, also zu welchem Zeitpunkt?
Ja, aber die Reklame für die Nutzung des Space Shuttle fing Ende der 70er Jahre an. Die Verwirklichung solcher Projekte dauert ja immer von der Idee bis zur Ausführung etliche Jahre. Also unter zehn Jahre läuft bei einem komplizierten Satellitenexperiment überhaupt nichts. Also sie müssen immer vorausplanen dabei und unsere Planung war am Anfang, das Ding mit dem Space Shuttle hochbringen zu lassen und oben rauswerfen zu lassen. Und dann würde der Satellit auf der Automotive fliegen. Damals wurden die Stadtkosten für Space Shuttle enorm niedrig eingesetzt. Und sozusagen der Transport in den Raum erschien damals außerordentlich billig. Es ist später dann ganz anders gekommen. Ein Space Shuttle hat dann am Ende 500 Millionen Dollar gekostet oder so. So viel hat das ganze ROSAT-Projekt nicht gekostet, sondern ungefähr 300 Millionen Dollar. Das mit allem Drum und Dran. Aber damals, Ende der 70er-Jahre erschien das also eine sinnvolle Geschichte. Wir mussten ja auch die Sache einigermaßen ökonomisch gestalten. Und das haben wir eben zusammen mit der DVR, heute DLR, haben wir das gemacht. Der Shuttle-Stadt musste dann begraben werden nach der Challenger-Katastrophe 1986. Danach ging nichts mehr. Wir hatten inzwischen Anfang der 80er Jahre eine Kollaboration bei ROSAT mit den Amerikanern angefangen und mit den Engländern, weil das BMFT darauf bestand, dass bei den wissenschaftlichen Großprojekten eine hinreichende internationale Beteiligung stattfindet.
Aus finanziellen oder wissenschaftlichen Erwägungen?
Das weiß ich nicht. Da müssen Sie jetzt BMFD fragen. Ich nehme an, weil man sich vergewissern wollte, dass das Projekt auch internationalen Maßstäben genügt. Also die Beteiligung der NASA an einem Projekt war damals natürlich eine Art Gütesiege. Ich habe dann mit dem bereits mehrfach erwähnten Diakoni mich darüber unterhalten. Der hat auf der amerikanischen Seite diese Sache sehr unterstützt. Es kam zu einer amerikanischen Beteiligung an ROSAT Anfang der 80er Jahre in Form des Shuttle-Stats zunächst mal und einem Detektor im Fokus von unserem ROSAT-Teleskop. Das war ein Detektor, den die schon auf dem Einstein-Satelliten geflogen hatten. Über die ESA haben wir den ROSAT zur Kollaboration innerhalb der ESA ausgeschrieben. Nach der ESA-Konvention mussten sowieso nationale Weltraumprojekte, und ROSAT war ein nationales Weltraumprojekt, der ESA angeboten werden zur Kollaboration. Dadurch wurden sie nicht ein ESA-gemanagtes Projekt, sondern ESA-Mitgliedsländer durften sich daran beteiligen. Da habe ich damals drei Vorschläge bekommen und habe einen Vorschlag von der Universität Leicester in England angenommen, die ein kleines EUV-Teleskop fliegen wollten, sozusagen als Huckepack, als Bypack-Experiment. EUV heißt Extremes Ultraviolett oder auch ganz weiche Röntgenstrahlung. Also das ist der Bereich zwischen Optisch-UV und dem Röntgenbereich. So kam da also diese internationale Kollaboration zustande mit den Amerikanern und mit den Engländern. Und immer noch war dann bis zum Jahr 1986 bis zur Challenger-Katastrophe geplant, das Ding auf dem Shuttle zu starten.
Was war der ursprünglich angedachte Zeitpunkt des Starts?
Ja, das konnte erst festgelegt werden, nachdem wir die ersten detaillierten Industriestudien gemacht haben. Damals mit MBW, Messerschmitt-Bökerblum und mit Dornier in Konkurrenz. Da wurden also Möglichkeiten des Satelliten studiert usw. Wir hatten dann Anfang der 80er Jahre zunächst mal etwa 1985, 1986 als Stadttermin uns erträumt. Aber die Dinge haben sich dann aus den verschiedenen Gründen hingezogen. Und es kam diese Challenger-Katastrophe zurück, die für uns im Grunde eine günstige Entwicklung einleitete. Weil in der Shuttle-Timeline landete der ROSAT Mitte der 90er Jahre oder so, 1995 oder so etwas. Nach der Challenger-Katastrophe wurde hier das ganze Shuttle-Programm zunächst mal eingestellt und danach ziemlich ausgedünnt. Und uns gelang es dann zusammen mit unseren amerikanischen Freunden, die NASA dazu zu bringen, ein Raketen stattzuspendieren.
Jetzt extra für ROSAT, weil man das nicht so weiter verzögern wollte, das Experiment.
Und dann musste der Satellit von der Shuttle-Version auf die Raketenversion umgestrickt werden.
Was ja keine unerhebliche Änderung ist.
Weil keine unerhebliche Änderung. Gott sei Dank war die Satellitenstruktur an sich stabil genug, um den Übergang zu machen. Im Shuttle war das Teleskop sozusagen quer zur Flugrichtung orientiert. Also in der Shuttle-Version des Shuttles. Das heißt, die Beschleunigungen beim Start und so weiter, die gingen quer zur Teleskoprichtung. In der Raketenversion wurde dann das Teleskop auf die Rakete draufgesetzt. Das heißt, die Startbeschleunigungen und die Belastungen und so weiter gingen in Längsrichtung des Teleskops. Das ist ein großer Unterschied für ein Teleskop, ob es quer belastet wird oder längs belastet wird. Das hat aber eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert. Gleichwohl, also mit den politischen Problemen zunächst mal also in Raketenstadt finanziert zu bekommen und mit diesen Unkonstruktionen hat das dann zu einer mehrjährigen Verzögerung geführt. Aber der Satellit wurde dann Mitte 1990 mit einer Tordell-Tarakete von Kepkenhavel ausgestattet und Bilderbuchstatt, da hat alles wunderbar funktioniert. Und er hat dann insgesamt achtenhalb Jahre lang gelebt, wissenschaftliche Daten geliefert. Die erste eigentlich sehr lange Astronomie-Mission, die es überhaupt gegeben hat. Und das war ein großer Gewinn gegenüber einem Shuttle-gestatteten Satelliten. Der Shuttle-gestattete Satellit wäre in eine sehr viel niedrigere Umlaufbahn gekommen und wäre dann schon nach anderthalb oder zwei Jahren verglüht. Dadurch, dass wir dann die Rakete hatten, konnten wir praktisch die Bahnhöhe vom ROSAT-Freie wählen. Und da haben wir hier Optimierungsüberlegungen angestellt und haben uns für eine Höhe von 580 Kilometern entschieden.
Das ist ja schon relativ weit.
Was schon relativ hoch ist, man muss eben schauen, dass man hoch kommt wegen der Lebensdauer und nicht zu hoch geht, weil man sonst in die Strahlungsgürtel zu stark reinkommt. Und in den Strahlungsgürteln hat man einen enormen Hintergrund von Teilchen und so weiter, die die Detektoren zustopfen.
Wo fängt dieser Strahlungsgürtel an?
Ja, das hängt von der geografischen, geomagnetischen Behalte ab.
Das heißt, die Frage ist, wie sehr man quasi noch im Schutz des Magnetfeldes der Erde bewegt. Das Max-Planck-Institut hat dann mit Ihnen als Leiter quasi den wissenschaftlichen Teil von ROSAT übernommen. Und das DLR hat die technische Durchführung des Staats und der, also nicht des Staats selber, das lag bei den Amerikanern, aber dann eben der Steuerung des Satelliten übernommen.
Die DLR hat das Management übernommen im Auftrag des BMFD, also des Ministeriums, und hat dann mit der Bodenstation in Weilheim und dem GSOC in Oberpfaffenhofen den Missionsbetrieb gemacht. Die Bahn von ROSAT hatten wir so gewählt, dass der Satellit vier oder fünfmal am Tag über München erscheint. Also im Empfangsbereich der Bodenstation in Weilheim. Und die Kontakte mit der Bodenstation waren dann jeweils typisch zehn Minuten lang etwa. Und in dieser kurzen Zeit wurden dann die Daten runtergespielt, die Messdaten, die der Satellit am Rest des Tages gesammelt hatte. Und die Kommandos hochgeschickt.
Für die neue Ausrichtung?
Für die neue Ausrichtung, für die neue Beobachtung, für die Parameter der Detektoren usw. usw. Und das lief so, dass wir das Beobachtungsprogramm festgelegt haben, also wo der Satellit wann hinschaut in seinem Orbit. Also die Missionsplanung haben wir hier gemacht. Und haben sie dann an das GSAC weitergegeben. Und die haben dann über die Antenne das Programm hochgeschickt zum Satelliten.
Wie muss man sich das jetzt vorstellen für einen Satelliten, der 1990 gestartet ist? Was für Datenmengen wurden von dem Satelliten überhaupt angesammelt, jetzt bei so einer Erdumrundung, bis sie dann wieder abgegeben werden an das Space-Operation Center?
Also die mittlere Datenrate war ein paar Kilobit pro Sekunde. Und ich glaube, die gesamte Datenmenge pro Tag waren 100 Megabyte oder so etwas von der Größenordnung.
100 Megabyte. Das ist aber schon relativ viel bei so einer niedrigen Datenrate. Das setzt ja dann sozusagen auch wirklich eine problemlose Kommunikation voraus. War es denn problemlos, die Kommunikation?
Weitgehend, ja. Also das hat eigentlich sehr gut funktioniert. Und also das GSAC hat einen wesentlichen Anteil am Erfolg dieser Mission durch diesen sehr intensiven Bodenbetrieb. Unser Glück war, dass zu der Zeit das GSAC noch nicht so sehr überlastet war mit allen möglichen anderen Aufgaben.
Wie es zum Beispiel die ISS-Mission Kolumbus Modul etc.
Das gab es damals in der Planung und so weiter. Aber wir hatten da praktisch die volle Zuwendung des GSAC. Jedenfalls in den ersten Jahren und später, als es dann Routine wurde, war die Zuwendung auch nicht mehr so entscheidend. In der Routine geht es dann natürlich einfacher. Das war ein großer Vorteil für uns. Auf der anderen Seite war der ROSAT ein Geschenk des Himmels für das GSAC, weil es für längere Zeit das einzige große Langzeitprojekt war, mit dem sie zu tun hatten. Die haben Satelliten positioniert und so weiter. Das dauert dann aber immer nur ein paar Tage oder ein paar Wochen. Und mit der Vorbereitung vielleicht auch ein bisschen länger. Aber diese 8,5 Jahre ROSAT-Betrieb sind für das GSAC sehr wichtig gewesen.
Wie äußert sich denn diese Hingabe zum Projekt? Was hätte auch schlechter laufen können? Wie muss man sich dann das Engagement des GSAC vorstellen?
Na gut, es gibt bei einem solchen Satellitenprojekt immer kritische Momente. Also wenn mal irgendwas schief geht. Wenn zum Beispiel die Bordcomputer verwirrt werden, zum Beispiel durch ein Strahlungsproblem. In dem in einem Register ein Bit umgeschmissen wird, dadurch, dass da ein Teilchen von der kosmischen Strahlung reinfährt. Oder so etwas.
Das passiert schon häufiger.
Das kommt also ab und zu mal vor. Das ist ab und zu vorgekommen. Und dann verliert der Satellit seine Lage. Dann geht er in den Safe Mode. Also in einen Sicherheitsmode, wo er sich selbstständig zur Sonne ausrichtet, sodass die Solarzellen die volle Sonne abkriegen. Das ist das Wichtigste. Dass der Satellit weiterhin Energie hat. Ansprechbar bleibt. Ein solcher Fehler ist bereits ein halbes Jahr nach dem Start aufgetreten. Da hat der Satellit die Orientierung verloren. Er wusste dann nicht mehr, wohin schaut. Er hat auch zufällig in die Sonne geschaut. Die Sonne hat über das Teleskop einen der Detektoren zerstört. Gott sei Dank hatten wir noch einen zweiten davon. Das hat dann letztlich die Mission nicht beeinträchtigt, aber es war eine riesen Aufregung, sowohl für das GSAC als auch für uns, den Satelliten wieder einzufangen und ihn wieder in das normale Programm zurückzuführen.
Wieder auf Linie zu bringen sozusagen. An der Stelle hat sich dann auch mal ganz konkret ausgezahlt, was ja eigentlich typisch ist für alle Sondenmissionen, Weltraummissionen, dass man eben einzelne wichtige Komponenten, redundant, mehrfach auslegt, mindestens doppelt, wenn nicht sogar dreifach. Das war dann sozusagen der Ersatzdetektor. Das war das wichtigste Instrument?
Ja, das war in den ersten fünf Jahren das wichtigste Instrument. Das war der von uns entwickelte Proportionalzähler, also ein bildgebender Röntgendetektor im Fokus des Teleskops. Der war glücklicherweise zweifach vorhanden. Dieserzähler hatte ein außerordentlich dünnes Eintrittsfenster, um die niederenergetische Röntgenstrahlung, die wir sehen wollten, in den Detektor eintreten zu lassen. Ein µ-Kunststoff, also ein Tausendstel Millimeter Kunststofffolie, war das Eintrittsfenster. Und als da die Sonne reingeschienen hat, ist das natürlich sofortig.
Das heißt, die Kunst bei der Steuerung des ROSAT war vor allem immer weg von der Sonne. Das Ding musste immer irgendwo dahin gucken, wo es hingucken wollte, aber wenn die Sonne in der Nähe war, musste man sich entsprechend abwenden. Das heißt, das Ding dreht sich auch quasi bei der Umrundung der Erde die ganze Zeit?
Nicht die ganze Zeit. Wir hatten zwei Missionsphasen. Das erste war eine Himmelsdurchmusterung, so wie sie Uhuru gemacht hatte. Also den ganzen Himmel abzunudeln.
Erstmal so eine Landkarte der Röntgenstrahlen.
Ja, und das haben wir gemacht durch einen langsamen Scan über den Himmel. Und zwar in einer Richtung senkrecht zur Sonne. Und da sich die Sonne am Sternenhimmel durch die Sternzeichen hindurch bewegt, hat sich diese Richtung am Himmel mit der Sonne sozusagen gedreht. Und dann in einem halben Jahr hatten wir den ganzen Himmel im Kasten.
Bis dann dieser Detektor kaputtging? War das dann schon abgeschlossen?
Das war praktisch abgeschlossen. Also die Himmelsüberdeckung war nicht ganz fehlerfrei. Da gab es ein paar Streifen, die noch nicht beobachtet wurden. Das haben wir dann aber später nachgeholt.
Wie weit konnte denn ROSAT überhaupt blicken? Sind das dann alles Objekte in unserer Milchstraße, die man sich anschaut?
Es sind Objekte in unserer Milchstraße, aber es sind vor allem auch sehr weit entfernte Objekte. Quasarer, Galaxienhaufen sind bei großen Entfernungen, also bei Entfernungen von hunderten Milliarden Lichtjahren. Mit ROSAT haben wir in der Himmelsdurchmusterung gut hunderttausend Röntgenquellen gefunden, kartografiert. Im Vergleich Uro hatte 300 und der nächstbeste Skysurvey der Amerikaner hatte 800 Quellen geliefert. Mit ROSAT hat man da, was den ganzen Himmel anbetrifft, einen enormen Quantensprung gemacht. Von einigen hundert bis auf hunderttausend Quellen. Die Objekte sind also Objekte unseres Sonnensystems, darauf kommen wir vielleicht nachher noch zu sprechen, Objekte aus unserer Milchstraße und dann ferne Milchstraßen aller Art. Von den nahen Galaxien, also Andromedanebel und den megalanischen Wolken, die sind ja relativ nahe, bis zu sehr entfernten Quasaren, bei sehr, sehr großen Rotverschiebungen.
Wie sieht man das denn diesem Objekt an, wie weit weg ist es?
Das konnten wir mit der Röntgenstrahlung alleine nicht beurteilen. Man muss dann von einem solchen Objekt eine tiefe optische Beobachtung machen und kann anhand der Verschiebung der Spektrallinien, der Rotverschiebung der Spektrallinien, die Entfernung bestimmen.
Das heißt, der ROSAT hatte auch noch eine optische Beobachtung?
Nein, nein, nein.
Eine separate Beobachtung?
Das ist eine separate Beobachtung. Die ROSAT-Daten wurden hier bei uns im Institut verarbeitet. Dann wurden die Koordinaten am Himmel bestimmt und so weiter, und die Flüsse, also die Intensitäten der Quellen und so weiter. Dann wurden anschließend optische Beobachtungen gemacht mit den Großteleskopen.
Aber man hat jetzt nicht alle 100.000 Quellen.
Nein, das kann man nicht. Das kann man nicht machen.
Auf was stürzt man sich denn dann?
Auf die Interessantesten.
Was macht die so interessant? Was sind die Interessanten? Was haben die für eine Signatur?
Wir hatten schon am Anfang über die Neutronensterne und Schwarze Löcher gesprochen. Aber auch zum Beispiel die normalen Sterne, wie unsere Sonne, zeigen eine mehr oder weniger starke Röntgenemission. Und mit ROSAT hat man zum ersten Mal eigentlich die Röntgenemission sämtlicher Sterntypen, die man kennt, beobachten können. Das hängt dann von vielen Parametern ab, von der Temperatur, von der Umdrehungsgeschwindigkeit des Sterns, also der Rotationsperiode des Sterns und von vielen anderen Dingen. Und man hat auf diese Weise auch sehr viel gelernt über die Aktivität von Sternen, wie Sonnenaktivität, die sich ja hier bei uns auf der Erde bemerkbar macht, also durch die magnetischen Stürme, durch die Beeinträchtigung, das spielt heute nicht mehr so eine Rolle, aber früher, des Funkverkehrs usw. Diese Einflüsse der Röntgen, der Aktivität, der Sonne auf unserer Erde, die versteht man natürlich viel besser, wenn man nicht die Sonne als isoliertes Objekt betrachtet, sondern wenn man sie im Vergleich mit ihren ganzen anderen ähnlichen Sternen betrachtet. Zum Beispiel ist mit ROSAT herausgefunden worden, dass die magnetische Aktivität von normalen Sternen, wie unsere Sonne, etwa ein Faktor 100 beträgt. Relativ zur optischen Emission der Sterne schwankt die Röntgenemission um ein Faktor 100. Die Sterne mit dem niedrigsten Level von Röntgenaktivität, die zeigen gerade so viel Abstrahlung von Röntgenstrahlung wie unsere Sonne in den sogenannten koronalen Löchern. Auf der Sonne ist die Röntgenabstrahlung nicht wie im Optischen relativ isotrop, also gleich verteilt über den ganzen Stern, sondern sie ist strukturiert nach den Magnetfeldern und so weiter. Es gibt die sogenannten koronalen Löcher, wo die Röntgenstrahlung, die aus der Sonne herauskommt, relativ schwach ist. Bei Sternen gleicher Typs, die also eine Sonnenmasse haben wie unsere Sonne, da gibt es welche, die bestehen praktisch nur aus einem solchen koronalen Loch. Also die ganze Oberfläche ist so aktiv wie die Sonne in den Minimumszeiten. Und auf diese Weise hat man also eine Menge gelernt über die aktiven Sterne.
Man kann sie auch besser klassifizieren.
Man kann sie besser klassifizieren und man versteht die Prozesse besser. Also ich meine, in der Astrophysik sind wir darauf angewiesen, aus den Beobachtungen, die wir machen, Schlüsse zu ziehen und dazu dienen Modelle, Modellvorstellungen und mit jeder Mission verfeinern sich die Modellvorstellungen, die man hat, über bestimmte Aspekte. In der Hinsicht hat ROSAT enorm viel gebracht. Also was die Röntgenaktivität von Sternen anbetrifft, die Röntgenemission von Sternen. Wir haben da ganz neue Sterntypen entdeckt. Zwischen den normalen Sternen und den Neutronensternen gibt es noch die sogenannten weißen Zwerge. Die sind weniger stark kollabiert als die Neutronensterne. Die haben da hat ein Kubikzentimeter nur ungefähr eine Tonne. Ein Kubikzentimeter. Eine Tonne.
Das könnte man fast noch mit sich herumtragen, so ein Kubikzentimeter.
Während die Neutronensterne einen Radius haben von etwa zehn Kilometern, haben diese weißen Zwerge einige tausend Kilometer. Die sind also ungefähr so groß wie die Erde, haben aber die Masse der Sonne ungefähr, größtenteilungsmäßig. Und wir haben mit ROSAT zum ersten Mal eine Art von weißen Zwergen entdeckt, die auf ihrer Oberfläche Kernbrennen haben.
Kernbrennen?
Kernfusionsreaktionen.
Ja.
Fusionsreaktionen.
Ist ja das, was die Sterne ohnehin tun.
Ja, was sie im Inneren haben. Im innersten Innern, wo es also besonders heiß ist. Und wir haben also weiße Zwerge entdeckt, die Material von einem Begleiter übergeschoben kriegen. Und dieses Material, das brennt an der Oberfläche des weißen Zwerg, der weiße Zwerg an sich ist erloschen. In dem gibt es keine Kernreaktionen mehr. Aber dieses frisch dazukommende Material von dem anderen Stern, das verbrennt auf der Oberfläche in Pulsionsreaktionen. Das ist also die einmalige Gelegenheit sozusagen, die Pulsionsreaktionen an der Oberfläche eines Sterns zu studieren, anzuschauen. Also diese Entdeckung haben wir gemacht im Zuge des Skyservice, indem wir uns hellequellen in den Magellanschen Wolken angeschaut haben.
Jetzt ist ja, gut, achteinhalb Jahre haben wir gesagt, war ROSAT aktiv deutlich länger, als man das wahrscheinlich am Anfang der Planung sich so hat erträumen können?
Ja, die internationalen Verträge mit der NASA und den Engländern sahen vor eine nominelle Betriebszeit von anderthalb Jahren, nach einer Einlaufphase von etwa zwei Monaten. Und die Verabredung war also, dass wir ein halbes Jahr Skyservice machen und dann für den Rest einfach Quellen anschauen und da Detailbeobachtungen machen. Und dieses Detailbeobachtungsprogramm hat also acht Jahre gedauert und nicht ein Jahr.
Und dadurch ist diese enorme Zahl an Beobachtungen zusammengekommen?
Ja, eine große Zahl von Beobachtungen, eine große Zahl von Entdeckungen. Dieses Detailbeobachtungsprogramm wurde ja international ausgeschrieben und da haben sich Tausende von Wissenschaftlern aus aller Welt getummelt.
Darauf falle ich nämlich jetzt gerade hinaus. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt achteinhalb Jahre lang so viel Daten sammelt und was hatten wir da, 100 Megabyte pro Tag war das die Menge an Daten, die wir genannt hatten. Auf jeden Fall wird noch mal ein bisschen gerechnet.
Ja, also das ist 20 Jahre her.
Ja, dass man das nicht immer so parat hat, das wundere mich jetzt schon, dass die Zahlen immer so geschossen kommen. Trotzdem ist das ja eine Menge an Material, was man ja so in Echtzeit überhaupt gar nicht verarbeiten kann. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass, wann war ROSAT dann beendet? Also 1990 war der Start, bis 1998 ist die Mission gelaufen.
Es ist eher ein Megabit pro Tag gewesen, nicht 100 Megabyte. Ich muss noch mal schauen. 2,5 x 10 hoch 3. 3600. Man vergisst das.
Ist da auch redundante Daten dabei? Oder ist wirklich alles, was runterkommt, neu?
Na gut, das hängt von den Gastbeobachtern ab. Der Gastbeobachter sagt, was er beobachtet haben will. Das ROSAT-Programm war dann Faktor 5 bis 6 überbucht. Also wir haben dann in internationalen Komitees aus den Vorschlägen, die wir bekommen haben, herausgesucht, die gemacht werden sollten. Also durch Gutachtergremien, die wir selbst organisiert haben. Und die wurden dann gemacht. Und das hing dann davon ab, was die Leute vorgeschlagen haben. Und manche Quellen sind oft beobachtet worden. Zum Beispiel bei einem Pulser, also so, der wird langsam, im Allgemeinen langsam, immer langsamer oder immer schneller. Da möchte man wissen, wie sich die Umdrehungsfrequenz mit der Zeit... Das heißt, da schaut man dann nach einem Jahr oder zwei noch mal drauf? Also das ist eine sehr vielfältige Angelegenheit. Auch wenn man zum Beispiel ausgedehnte Quellen kartografieren will, dann muss man sozusagen mosaikartig das ganze Ding abtasten. Das dauert auch Zeit. Und dabei werden dann einzelne Quellen auch natürlich auch immer wieder beobachtet, die sozusagen in den Überlappungsbereichen von dem Mosaik liegen.
Ich finde das nochmal ganz interessant, diesen wissenschaftlichen Prozess auch nochmal kurz zu beleuchten. Also man macht sich das ja immer nicht klar. Man denkt so, okay, alles klar. Man hat jetzt hier den Satelliten, man hat die Instrumente gebaut, man hat eine relativ klare Vorstellung davon, was man machen will. Es gab ja auch im ersten halben Jahr diesen klaren Auftrag, wir suchen jetzt erstmal alles ab, wir machen eine neue Landkarte und schauen überhaupt erstmal, wo was ist. Und dann machen wir uns auf und schauen uns die interessantesten Sachen an. Aber irgendwann kommt man dann wahrscheinlich an so einen Punkt, wo sich das Projekt der gesamten wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft weltweit öffnet. War das von vornherein so vorgesehen oder kam das jetzt nur durch diese unerwartet lange Laufzeit?
Der Sky Survey gehörte unserem Institut. Also der ist von unserem Institut ausgewertet worden, weil ich auf dem Standpunkt stand. Das muss eine Gruppe machen. Man kann nicht den ganzen Himmel zerfleddern in einzelne Teile und jeder macht mal sein Stückchen und zum Schluss wird das zusammen gemacht. Das gibt einen Flickerteppich. Die Himmelströchennusterung ist von unserem Institut bearbeitet worden. Die Detailbeobachtungen wurden dann für die Gastbeobachter gemacht, wobei wir selber auch solche Beobachtungen vorgeschlagen haben. Wir haben natürlich selber an diesem Detailbeobachtungsprogramm kräftig teilgenommen, hier im Institut, und zusammen mit Auswärtigen und anderen deutschen Gruppen usw. und auch ausländischen Gruppen.
Das heißt, über die ganze Laufzeit von ROSAT war man eigentlich permanent die ganze Zeit mit diesem Projekt beschäftigt?
Ja, jeden Tag. Unsere Techniker liefen Tag und Nacht, und am Wochenende mit diesen großen Telefonen herum, die man damals hatte.
Ach, diese Frühzeit-Mobiltelefonen, diese Pockys.
Genau, das waren ziemliche Yonnies, und die liefen damit die ganze Zeit rum, weil man immer auf der Hut sein musste, falls irgendetwas passiert. Wenn im Satelliten irgendetwas stößt, dann müssen alle ran und müssen Feuerwehr spielen.
Und gab es auch so kosmische Ereignisse, die so einen Feuerwehreinsatz erfordert haben, dass irgendetwas entdeckt wurde, wo man sich gesagt hat, da müssen wir jetzt mal schnell drauf schauen?
Ja, dazu gab es die sogenannte Target of Opportunity Beobachtung. Also das waren dann Beobachtungen außer der Reihe. Und die konnte jeder, wer auch immer, mit einem Proposal bei mir vorschlagen. Und ich habe dann entschieden, ob das gemacht wird oder nicht. Man muss dann abwägen, was ist wichtiger, das bereits verabschiedete Programm abzuarbeiten oder jetzt eine solche Ad-hoc-Beobachtung dazwischenzuschalten. Das hat aber sehr gut funktioniert. Und es hat also bei den Entscheidungen, die manchmal auch negativ waren und Ablehnungen gegeben hat, hat es also nie irgendwelche großen Probleme.
Aber was für Opportunities waren denn das?
Zum Beispiel, wenn eine Supernova-Explosion passiert. 1993 gab es eine sehr prominente Supernova-Explosion. Und da konnten wir mit ROSAT wenige Tage nach der Explosion hinschauen und haben auch Röntgenstrahlen beobachtet. Und das hat dann zu den wissenschaftlichen Analysen auch wesentlich beigetragen.
Wer hat die entdeckt? Die Supernova?
Die Supernovae werden im Allgemeinen mit optischen Teleskopen entdeckt. Und es gibt dann die Telegramme von der Internationalen Astronomischen Union. Damals ging das über Telegramme. Die IAU-Telegramme, in denen die weltweit annonciert werden.
Also es ist die internationale Astronomische Union.
Und dann schaut man dahin, so schnell wie möglich.
Ist eigentlich ein Riesenglück, dass man die entdeckt? Oder ist die Beobachtung des Himmels mittlerweile so total, dass einem keine mehr entgeht?
Es gibt Leute, es gibt Institute, die sich auf die Supernova-Entdeckung spezialisiert haben. Die gucken sich also den ganzen Himmel, oder jedenfalls den Teil des Himmels, den sie von ihrem Standpunkt her sehen, an. Und melden jedes verdächtige Ereignis. Die Astronomie heute ist fantastisch organisiert. Die Beobachtungsstationen sind untereinander vernetzt. Wir arbeiten hier auch sehr eng mit der ESO zusammen. Die haben ja die großen Teleskope, die in Chile stehen.
Auf der Südhalbkugel.
Auf der Südhalbkugel. Wir haben auch viel mit dem Abelsbes Teleskop zusammengearbeitet bei ROSAT.
Das heißt, wenn diese Supernova-Jäger Anzeichen entdecken, da könnte was sein, dann richten die großen Teleskope sich drauf.
Genau.
Und dann kann man schauen, in dem Fall 1993 ging schwer was ab. Und dann hat sich auch ROSAT entsprechend dem zugewandt. Wie klein ist denn dieses Beobachtungsfenster? Wie schnell laufen diese Supernova ab? Wann ist der interessante Teil vorbei? Man hat alles verpasst.
Na gut, das ist natürlich eine hochdynamische Angelegenheit. Die Intensitäten der Supernova in den verschiedenen Spektralbereichen entwickeln sich verschieden. Im Optischen anders als im Röntgenbereich. Das ganze Theater erstreckt sich über einen Zeitraum von Monaten bis Jahren. Es gibt Supernova-Überreste relativ nah. Die kann man ja noch nach Hunderten oder Tausenden von Jahren sehen. Zum Beispiel der Cap-Nebel, der es am 4. Juli 1054 explodiert. Das ist heute eine der hellsten Röntgenquellen am Himmel. Supernovae sind relativ seltene Ereignisse. In unserer Milchstraße finden etwa drei im Jahrhundert statt. Aber da man wahnsinnig viele Galaxien sieht am ganzen Himmel, und in allen Galaxien die Sternexplosionen etwa mit der Rate passieren, hat man dutzende, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, viele, viele Supernovae-Ereignisse im Jahr, die dokumentiert werden. Interessant sind natürlich die Näheren, wo man dann besonders viel detaillierter Information sammeln kann.
Wie zum Beispiel Androm in der Nebel.
Wie zum Beispiel im Jahr oder in anderen näheren Galaxien, ein Stückchen weiter weg sind noch als Androm in der Nebel.
In der lokalen Gruppe. Bist du schön heiß? Lokal ist die Gruppe ja gar nicht.
Ich meine ein anderer Aufreger, der dann auch zu solchen besonderen Aktionen geführt hat, war die Entdeckung der Röntgenstrahlung von Kometen.
Die sind doch ganz kalt.
Richtig. Kometen gelten als kalt. Die werden als schmutzige Schneeberge apostrophiert. Im Jahr 1996 bekam ich einen Vorschlag aus den USA, einen bestimmten Kometen, der gerade entdeckt worden war, mit ROSAT zu beobachten. Man hätte noch nie einen Kometen im Röntgenbereich gesehen. Deswegen war das für mich eine sehr schwere Entscheidung. Sollen wir jetzt dafür eine andere Beobachtung opfern? Sollen wir das Ding dazwischen schieben oder nicht? Ich habe es glücklicherweise gemacht. Ich habe gesagt, lass uns doch mal gucken, was da los ist. Und in der Tat eine helle Röntgenquelle. Kann das der Grund für sein? Das hat man dann im Laufe der Monate danach langsam herausklamüsert. Ich bin da selbst auch daran beteiligt gewesen, vor allem aber Herr Dennerl hier bei uns im Institut. Die physikalische Situation ist die folgende. Sie haben den Kometen und wenn der Komet in die Nähe der Sonne kommt, dann entwickelt er ja diesen Schweif. Durch die Sonnenstrahlung verdampft von dem Eis, von dem Schneeball etwas. Es steht eine Wasserwolke um den Kometen herum, die man auch im Optischen sehen kann. Das ist die sogenannte Kuma. Wir haben dann gefunden, dass genau diese Kuma, also eine ausgedehnte Wasserwolke vor dem Kometen in Sonnenrichtung, dass die intensive Röntgenstrahlung aussendet. Der Prozess, der dabei eine Rolle spielt, ist eigentlich ganz einfach, wenn man mal weiß, wie es geht. Die Sonne bläst einen heißen Sonnenwind ab. Dieser Sonnenwind hat 1-2 Millionen Grad und enthält hochionisierte Stickstoff- und Sauerstoffatome usw. Wenn dieser Sonnenwind mit dieser neutralen Wasserdampfwolke, der kalten Wasserdampfwolke zusammenstößt, dann werden die Sonnenwind-Ionen entladen. Die klauen sich dann Elektronen von dem Wasser, entladen sich, und dann gehen sie in einen angerichtenen Zustand über und durch Emission von Röntgenstrahlung in den Grundzustand. Was wir sehen, ist im Grunde der heiße Sonnenwind, der seine Ladung entlädt in der Wasserdampffolge des Kometen. Das ist ein Prozess, das ist eine von den vielen Entdeckungen gewesen, die da gemacht worden sind. Und die ist besonders überraschend gewesen, weil, wie sie auch vermutet haben, ein Komet so kalt wie kann der Röntgenstrahlung aussehen. Und dann haben wir uns hingesetzt und haben im ROSAT-Survey...
Noch mal kurz zu den Kometen. Wie nah an der Sonne war denn der, als er beobachtet wurde? War der so auf Erddistanz oder noch näher dran?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr auswendig. Aber so etwa von der Größenordnung. Ja, also die Kometen laufen ja um auf hochexzentrischen Bahnen, oder auch hyperbolischen Bahnen um die Sonne herum. Und die fangen dann erst an, richtig als Komet in Erscheinung zu treten, wenn sie in Sonnennähe kommen. Also bei zwei-, drei- oder vierfachen Entfernungen der Erde von der Sonne fängt das dann so ungefähr an.
Okay, also ab Mars wird es dann irgendwie langsam interessant. Das heißt, wenn die Kometen weiter draußen sind, dann würde es auch wirklich wenig bringen, sie in einer Röntgenstrahlung zu bewahren.
Mars ist natürlich ein anderes Stichwort, Röntgenstrahlung von Mars. Das haben wir mit einem Nachfolgesatelliten von ROSAT gesehen. Venus kann man im Röntgenbereich sehen, Mars. Jupiter ist eine Art kleiner Pulsar, ein Mikropulsar sozusagen. Der dreht sich sehr schnell, er hat starke Magnetfelder. Der hat ähnlich wie die Pulsare Hochenergieprozesse, die zur Emission von Röntgenstrahlung führen.
Das heißt, die Röntgenstrahlung ist eigentlich ein sehr universeller Bereich, in dem sich das Universum umwacht.
Was man eigentlich gelernt hat in diesen 40 oder 50 Jahren Röntgenastronomie, ist, dass die Temperaturen von vielen Objekten sehr hoch sind. Das wusste man ja früher überhaupt nicht. Die Sterne, die man sieht, haben Temperaturen von paartausend Grad bis zigtausend Grad. Das sind die Temperaturen, wo optisches Licht entsteht. Aber im Röntgenbereich haben wir es mit Temperaturen zu tun von Millionen bis Milliarden Grad. Und wir haben festgestellt, dass ein großer Teil der Materie im Kosmos, auch der sichtbaren Materie, auf so hohen Temperaturen ist. Das sind also Materiezustände, die weit von dem entfernt sind, was wir hier auf der Erde haben, mit unseren 270 oder 300 Grad Kelvin oder so. Ein anderes Beispiel, ich hatte schon die Quasare entdeckt. Die Quasare sind starke Röntgenstrahler. Die sind ja in sehr großen Entfernungen, die sind also aus kosmologischer Sicht sehr interessant. Eine andere Sorte von Röntgenquellen, die auch kosmologisch sehr interessant sind, sind die Galaxienhaufen. Die Galaxien, wie unsere Milchstraße oder so, die sind ja nicht statistisch regelos im Kosmos verteilt, sondern die ballen sich mehr oder weniger in sogenannten Galaxienhaufen zusammen. Das kann man sich so vorstellen wie so ein Mückenschwarm am Abend. Da ist eine Wolke von Galaxien, die durch einander wimmeln und mit hohen Geschwindigkeiten tausenden Kilometer pro Sekunde in dieser Wolke von Galaxien umherfliegen. Diese Galaxienhaufen haben sehr starke Röntgenstrahlung. Das ist ein heißes Plasma, 100 Millionen Grad oder so, was zwischen den Galaxien existiert und was auch durch die Galaxien, die dann durchfliegen, mit hoher Geschwindigkeit dauern, nachgeheizt wird.
Das heißt, das ist etwas, was Sie aus unserer Galaxie gar nicht kennen?
Nein.
Die Milchstraße ist von so etwas nicht umgeben?
Die Milchstraße hat eine Halo aus heißem Gas. Ja, aber das ist sozusagen eine lokale heiße Wolke, die von der Milchstraße durch die Gravitation gehalten wird. Aber danach fängt dann der intergalaktische Raum an. Beim Galaxienhaufen haben Sie Tausende von Galaxien, die in einem Haufen sitzen. Sie hatten schon vorhin das Stichwort lokale Gruppe genannt. Also die lokale Gruppe ist ja auch eine kleine Ansammlung von Galaxien, zu der unsere Milchstraße gehört. Stellen Sie sich vor, eine Ansammlung von Milchstraßen von Tausenden oder zigtausenden von Milchstraßen. Unsere lokale Gruppe gehört wahrscheinlich auch zu einem Ausläufer eines solchen Galaxienhafens in den Außenbereichen. Diese Galaxienhafen sind sehr, sehr intensive Röntgenquellen. Wir wissen, dass diese Röntgenstrahlung nicht von den einzelnen Mitgliedsgalaxien kommt, sondern von einem heißen Gas, das in diesen ganzen Haufen erfüllt. In diesem heißen Gas, das Temperaturen hat 100 Millionen Grad, da steckt mehr Masse drin als in den Galaxien, die man sehen kann.
Ist das dann auch der Geburtsort für neue Sterne?
Nein, Sterne werden aus kaltem Gas gebildet, indem sich das anzieht. Dieses heiße Gas hat aber sehr nützliche Eigenschaften. Wenn Sie sich vorstellen, Sie haben einen Galaxienhaufen, der hat eine bestimmte Gravitationsanziehung. Unter anderem. Dadurch sind die Galaxien auch gewissermaßen aneinander gebunden und können nicht weglaufen. Die fliegen da umeinander wie die Mücken in einen Mückenschwarm. Dieses heiße Gas hat eine bestimmte Verteilung. Aus der Verteilung kann man die Gravitationsfelder bestimmen in diesem Galaxienhaufen. Diese heiße Gaswolke, die man da sieht an der Stelle des Galaxienhaufen, die ist nur dort, weil diese heiße Wolke von der Gravitation der ganzen Galaxien und des ganzen Haufens festgehalten wird. Und man kann dadurch, indem man diese Röntgen emittierenden heißen Gaswolken beobachtet, kann man die gesamte Masse des Galaxienhaufens bestimmen. Und man findet eben, dass nur ein ganz kleiner Teil, ein paar Prozent aus der normalen Materie, aus der die Galaxien und wir bestehen, also der sogenannten barionischen Materie, ein und die Gravitation, die man sieht, indem man die Daten analysiert, die deutet darauf hin, dass da sehr viel dunkler Materie enthalten ist. Dunkler Materie, die nicht barionischer Natur sein kann, sondern die muss ganz anderer Natur sein, die ist bisher völlig ungeklärt. Das ist also eins der großen kosmologischen Rätsel, woher kommt eigentlich diese dunkle Materie und woraus besteht sie? Das weiß kein Mensch. Wir wissen nur, dass sie da sind. Sonst, wenn sie nicht da wäre in den Galaxienhafen, dann würden die auseinanderfliegen.
Das heißt, mit der Röntgenastronomie kratzt man auch wirklich an den großen Unbekannten der derzeitigen Universumsforschung?
Ja, und mit einem der ROSAT-Nachfolger, an dem jetzt hier bei uns am Institut gearbeitet wird, das ist ein Projekt Erosita. Damit soll ein Sky Survey gemacht werden mit nun viel verbesserten Instrumenten verglichen mit ROSAT nach 25 Jahren. Bei dem Objekt interessiert man sich für die Verteilung der Materie im ganz grossen kosmologischen Maßstab. Da geht es um die Fragen dunkle Energie. Also wie kann man die dunkle Energie fassen? Wie kann man noch bessere Beobachtungen über die dunkle Energie gewinnen? Die dunkle Energie ist ja nach dem, was wir heute, nach den heutigen Vorstellungen, die dominierende Energieform im Kosmos. Der Löwenanteil ist, der Gesamtenergie des Kosmos steckt in dieser dunklen Energie und im Gegensatz zu der dunklen Materie, die gravitativ wirkt und die Materie zusammenhält, wirkt die dunkle Energie treibend und treibt den ganzen Kosmos auseinander und bringt ihn zu einer beschleunigten Bewegung. Diese Phänomene, die mit der Kosmologie zusammenhängen, mit der langfristigen Entwicklung unseres Kosmos, die sind im Moment enorm aktuell. Das wird ein Thema sein von dieser neuen Mission, die wir planen, Erosita, die in zwei oder drei Jahren startet. Das ist eine Kollaboration zwischen unserem Institut und der rossischen Raumfahrtagentur. Die Rossen stellen die Plattform, also den Satelliten, zur Verfügung. Wir fliegen das Erosita-Teleskop darauf, die Rossen haben ein eigenes Instrument, das die Erosita sozusagen unterstützt. Gemanagt wird das Ganze auch wieder von der DLR. Das ist im Grunde eigentlich wieder eine ähnliche Kollaboration.
Und dann auch vom Gesock in Oberpfaffenhofen?
Ja, noch nicht. Mein Vorschlag ist es, das zu machen. Im Moment ist die Baseline für das Projekt, dass man die russischen Raumstationen benutzt. Allerdings gibt es dabei gewisse Überdeckungsprobleme. Von daher gesehen wäre es gut, wenn da noch eine andere Bodenstation sich beteiligt. Das ist also auch ein Vorschlag von mir, den ich neulich mit dem Leiter des GSLC besprochen habe. Wir hatten übrigens auch bei ROSAT Backup-Stationen von der NASA. Also im Notfall, wenn der Satellit außer Kontrolle geriet, dann konnten wir die NASA-Bodenstationen zu Hilfe nehmen. Der Satellit erschien ja nur fünfmal am Tag hier kurz über München, aber für den Rest der Zeit war er sozusagen unbeaufsichtigt. Diese Notfallsituation ist dann auch ein paar Mal eingetreten und hat auch geholfen. Die Bodensstationen unter anderem sind sehr gut vernetzt, die helfen sich gegenseitig in Notfällen.
Auch die Bodensstationen sind hier bei Raumzeit schon ein paar Mal zur Sprache gekommen, werden sicherlich auch mal Inhalt eines längeren Gesprächs sein. So wie wir hier auch zum Kapitel ROSAT auch noch einen weiteren Beitrag planen, denn ROSAT war jetzt ja nicht nur im Gespräch, weil es ein großer wissenschaftlicher Erfolg war, diese Mission, sondern weil das Lied mittlerweile außer Kontrolle geraten ist und in absehbarer Zeit vermutlich unkontrolliert abstürzen wird. Wie ist es dazu? Kommen Sie da einen Einblick, wie es mit der Mission zu Ende gegangen ist?
Ja, also ich verfolge das natürlich. Also der ROSAT ist seit Februar 1999 außer Kontrolle, ist passiv. Also man kann ihn nicht mehr beeinflussen. Er kommt durch die Bremsung in der Restatmosphäre, die es darum gibt, langsam immer tiefer. Im Moment ist er auf ungefähr 310 Kilometern Höhe. Und wahrscheinlich wird er noch in diesem Jahr dann in die Erdatmosphäre eintauchen. Und ROSAT hat einige große Teile, das größte Teil, was den Absturz überleben wird, ist das Spiegelsystem. Über das Spiegelsystem haben wir hier noch gar nicht gesprochen in diesem Gespräch. Aber vielleicht sollte man darüber nochmal ein paar Worte sagen. Dieses Spiegelsystem besteht aus vier ineinander geschachtelten Rosateleskopen. Die Spiegelflächen sind aus Cerodur, also die Spiegelkörper sind aus Cerodur.
Das ist extrem hitzebeständiges Glas.
Das ist dieses hitzebeständige Glas, was man auch auf den Kochfeldern in den Küchen hat. Das ist eine knappe Tonne. Dieser Glaskörper wird wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Form geschmolzen oder sonst wie unten ankommen. Vielleicht auch ein paar andere Teile. Also das weiß ich nicht. Und das wird irgendwann gegen Ende des Jahres passieren. Dieser Vorgang wird ja beobachtet durch ESOC, also von der ESA-Brundenstation und auch vom GSOC und von der DLR. Ich denke, man kann erst in den letzten Tagen vor dem Runterkommen voraussagen, in welcher Gegend das passieren wird. Also dieser Abbremsvorgang in der Atmosphäre, der ist von der Sonnenaktivität abhängig. Und die Sonnenaktivität ist natürlich unterschiedlich. Das ist keine gleichförmige Brems. Und in den letzten Tagen vorher kann man dann das Impactgebiet, wo das Ding runterkommt, in der Länge, also in Richtung der Bahn, wohl auf einige hundert Kilometer und in der Breite auf zig Kilometer genau festlegen. Und bisher sind durch einen Sateliten der Runde viele Sateliten runtergekommen und viele Satelitenteile. Also in der frühen Zeit der Raumfahrt hat man sich darum nicht gekümmert.
Das kam einfach runter.
Das kam einfach irgendwo runter. Und meistens hat man es dann gar nicht gemerkt, weil die meisten Gebiete auf der Erde sind ja... Wasser. Wasser, Wüsten und andere unwirtliche Gegenden, wo es gar keine Menschen gibt. Also das werden wir sehen. Das werden wir dann irgendwann im Dezember, vielleicht auch etwas eher oder auch etwas später im nächsten Frühjahr. Aber das Ende ist nahe. Also ich verfolge das, indem ich mir alle paar Tage mal die Bahnhöheanschauern von ROSAT, die jetzt deutlich abnimmt, die die ganze Zeit abgenommen hat. Aber es wird jetzt immer schneller. Es geht immer schneller. Je dichter die Atmosphäre wird, wo wir reinkommen, umso schneller geht das natürlich.
Ja, wir werden die Bahn hier bei Raumzeit auch nochmal genauer verfolgen, wie ich schon angedeutet habe, noch ein separates Gespräch führen, die sich ganz konkret jetzt um diesen besonderen Auftrag der Beobachtung dieses Absturzes dreht. Haben wir noch etwas ganz wichtiges vergessen, was man noch erwähnen sollte?
Vielleicht sollte ich doch noch etwas sagen über die Firmen, die beteiligt waren. Also wir hatten eine hervorragende Zusammenarbeit mit der Firma Dornier, die dann später im EADS aufgegangen ist. Die war Hauptauftragnehmer für diesen Satelliten und hat also den Satelliten sozusagen als Ganzes gebaut. Die Firma MBB, jetzt auch im EADS, die Firma MBB war für das Lageregelungs- und Messsystem zuständig. Eine sehr komplizierte Mimik, über die man stundenlang reden könnte. Auch über das, was man daraus gelernt hat aus dem Betrieb, aus dem ROSAT-Betrieb. Das war nämlich auch für Anwendungssatelliten sehr wichtig. Dann aber auch die Firma Zeiss, die das Röntgenteleskop gebaut hat. Das ROSAT-Teleskop stand für Jahre im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde als die glattesten Spiegel, die jemals gemacht wurden. Die Mikrorauigkeit der Oberfläche von den Spiegeln muss sehr klein sein, damit die Röntgenstrahlen, die reflektiert werden, anständig reflektiert werden und nicht gestreut werden. Die Mikrorauigkeit von ROSAT war 0,25 Nanometer, also der Rippel auf der Oberfläche. Das ist eine unheimliche Glattheit. Wenn Sie die Spiegeldimension von ROSAT mal auf den Bodensee umrechnen.
Also wenn der Spiegel so groß wäre wie der Bodensee?
Der Spiegel hat 80 Zentimeter, der Bodensee hat ungefähr 80 Kilometer. Das ist also ein 10 hoch 5, 100.000 fach, 0,25 mal 10 hoch 5. Ich vergesse diese Zahl leider auch immer wieder. Das sind 0,25 mal 10 hoch 4.
25 µm, 25 µm wären es noch, wenn der Spiegel so groß wäre, wie der Bodensee. Also immer noch bei einer 100.000-fachen Vergrößerung etwas, was man überhaupt nicht mit dem bloßen Auge wahrnehmen kann. Wird nochmal geprüft, dass hier auch die Potenzierung greift.
Ja, ja, man muss das ja... Ja, also das war eine ganz besondere Leistung von der Firma Zeiss. Und man hat eine Menge dabei gelernt. Das Spiegelsystem war größer als das größte bis dahin gebaute amerikanische Spiegelsystem. Das hatte 56 Zentimeter Öffnung und wir hatten 84 Zentimeter. Aber unsere Mikroerhöhigkeit, die waren Faktor 6 besser als bei den Amerikanern. Das hat sich in der Schärfe der Bilder ausgezahlt. Also ich wollte nur noch sagen, wir hatten eine hervorragende Zusammenarbeit mit der Industrie auf der einen Seite, den deutschen Weltraumfirm mit der Firma Zeiss, mit dem Management durch die DLR, dem GSAC als Bodenulation. Ich habe immer gesagt, also es ist insofern ein Glücksfall gewesen, weil bei ROSAT eigentlich jeder Partner genau das gemacht hat, was er selber am besten konnte. Das ist nicht immer so bei solchen internationalen Geschichten, weil da oft nach dem Prinzip der geografischen Verteilung und so weiter dann Aufgabenpakete hin und her geschoben werden müssen, bis es stimmt. Und das war also wirklich sehr gut. Und natürlich der Beitrag unseres Instituts war auch nicht unerheblich. Wir haben hier die ganze Fokalinstrumentierung selbst gebaut. 400 Kilogramm an hochkomplizierter Hardware mit den Detektoren, mit dem Karussell zum Drehen, zum Einbringen der verschiedenen Detektoren in den Fokus von dem Teleskop, mit dem Gassystem zum Durchfluss der Proportionalzähler. Das alles hier ist bei uns im Institut passiert. Wir haben also hier raumfahrtqualifizierte Hardware hergestellt. Also nicht nur Prototypen, die dann in der Industrie bei MBB oder Dorn, in der Raumfahrt festgemacht wurden, sondern das ist hier bei uns im Institut passiert. Und das ist die Besonderheit hier an diesem Institut. Wir verbinden also die Wissenschaft mit den technologischen Aspekten der Hardware. Und das ist typisch für unser Institut. Also wir machen Wissenschaft auf der einen Seite mit unseren Projekten. Und die Wissenschaft ist der Treiber bei den Projekten. Aber wir engagieren uns auch selbst, indem wir vor allem die Detektoren, also die Bilddetektoren, die Spektrometer und so weiter, selber entwickeln. Und das ist die Besonderheit bei unserem Institut. Viele andere Institute überlassen das auch der Industrie. Also die geben ihre Ideen in die Industrie. Aber wir machen diese Dinge selbst. Und das hat einen großen Vorteil, wenn Sie die Detektoren und Spektrometer und so weiter selber bauen, dann wissen Sie selbst am besten, wie die Daten entstehen, die Sie da später dann interpretieren wollen.
Wo man mit Toleranzen rechnen muss, wo man mit Fehlerwerten arbeiten muss etc. Immer ein großer Vorteil, beides unter Kontrolle zu haben.
Und vielleicht noch zum Schluss, also ROSAT hat viele tausend, ich glaube es sind inzwischen über 8.000 oder fast 9.000 wissenschaftliche Publikationen erbracht, an dem tausende von Wissenschaftlern teilgenommen haben. Von den etwa 30 Röntgensatelliten, die es bisher gegeben hat, steht ROSAT an der zweiten Stelle, was den wissenschaftlichen Ertrag anbetrifft. An dem Ertragreichsten, das ist eine NASA-Mission mit dem Namen Chandra, sind wir auch beteiligt, da haben wir ein Instrument dazu beigesteuert. Chandra ist aber ungefähr ein Faktor 6, 7, 8 teurer gewesen als ROSAT. Das sind finanziell ganz andere Dimensionen gewesen.
Ja, jetzt haben wir es, würde ich sagen. Das war ein super Einblick in das ROSAT-Projekt, wie schon angedeutet. Wir werden uns ja auch nochmal der Absturzproblematik separat widmen, aber war uns auf jeden Fall auch ein Anliegen, hier erstmal den wissenschaftlichen Wert und die technische Komplexität des Projektes in den Mittelpunkt zu rücken. Insofern sage ich Danke für den Beitrag. Und ja, auch an alle Hörer wieder Danke fürs Zuhören, dass hier immer durchgehalten wird bis zum Ende der interessanten Gespräche. Und mit interessanten Gesprächen geht es natürlich hier auch bald wieder weiter bei Raumzeit.